يعني منذ يعني بعام 2022 كانت ذروه
التهريب من الاراضي السوريه الى الاراضي
الاردنيه كانت تهريب عباره عن تهريب مواد
مخدره من هالكبتاجون من هالحشيش منها جميع
انواع المواد المخدره لكن اللافت في هذا
البيان اليوم الذي اصدره الجيش الاردني ان
هذه الطياره المسيره كانت مفخخه وكانت
تهرب قنابل يدويه واسلحه وهذه يعني المره
الاولى التي يتم الاعلان فيها بالتفاصيل
عن المضغوطات كان هناك تهريب للاسلحه
وتهريب ايضا للمخدرات للعلم في الفتره
يعني خلال الثلاث اشهر الاشهر الاولى من
هذا العام لم يكن هناك يعني عمليات تهريب
اسبوعيه لان كانت
البيانات الرسميه من القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه الاردنيه شبه يوميه او شبه
اسبوعيه يكون هناك تهريب من الاراضي
السوريه لكن خلال هذه لم يكن هناك كانت
الامور تهدئه ربما كان هناك ايضا يعني
قنوات دبلوماسيه استخدمها الاردن مع
الجانب السوري لتخفض هذه
التهريب من المعروف ان يعني الفراغ الذي
تركه الروس في الجنوب السوري مللاه
ايضا الميليشيات التابعه لايران من حزب
الله لذلك يعني تعتبر سوريا هي مصنع
للكبتاجون ومصنع للمخدرات ويتم تهريب هذه
المخدرات من خلال
الحدود الاردنيه الشماليه والشماليه
الشرقيه يكون الجيش الاردني يحبط بشكل شبه
يومي هذه العمليات وتنشط هذه العمليات
ايضا في يعني فتره
الشتاء حيث يكون هناك الاجواء مغبره وتكون
ايضا اجواء تابعه نعم يعني ان يعني تصبح
ماده التي يتم تهريبها من المخدرات الى
القنابل والاسلحه الا يثير ذلك
مخاوف السلطات الامنيه الاردنيه من تنفيذ
عمليات ربما
من يعني الخطر خطر الامني بالاردن
بكل تاكيد ان هذه يعني هذه العمليات
عمليات التهريب الاسلحه وتهريب ايضا اليوم
القنابل اليدويه بالاضافه الى ان تكون هنا
هذه الطائره هي مفخخه لكي لا يتم ضبطها
بالشكل يعني
بشكلها الكامل
ولكي ايضا يعني لا يعرف او لا يتم التعرف
على المضغوطات داخل هذه الطائره اليوم
يعني الاردن بالتاكيد ان هذه ربما ستكون
نقطه تحول في المنطقه او منطقه الحدود
ليتم بالضبط بشكل اكبر ويتم يعني الجيش
الاردني يحكم قبضته اكثر في هذه المنطقه
لان يعني العمليات التي يتم السيطره عليها
من قبل او يتم الاحباطها قبل هذه العمليات
كانت من قبل الجيش الاردني تحبط بالداخل
السوري لكن هذه الطائره دخلت الى الاراضي
الاردنيه وتم احباطها داخل الاراضي
الاردنيه لهذا لذلك هذا التحول ربما يعني
سيثير
مخاوف
الاردن حول وصول هذه المتفجرات او هذه
العمليات مثل عمليات تهريب الاسلحه وتهريب
القنابل اليدويه ماذا سيفعل فيها داخل
داخل ماذا سيفعل بهذه المواد داخل الاراضي
الاردنيه بالتاكيد ان هناك سيكون بالتاكيد
ستستخدم داخل الاراضي الاردنيه وسيتم يعني
ايصالها لاحد الاشخاص لذلك هذه التحقيقات
وكافه مجريات هذه العمليه عمليه احباط
سيكون هناك تحقيقات موسعه وسيتم الاعلان
عنها بشكل اكبر ان شاء الله